ramsay show you can be intentional about
your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
cart rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality and host of the ken
coleman show
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
the ken coleman show is all about your
career all about getting in a job and in
a career field that you
love doing work that matters that you're
good at
and where you can actually show up and
be glad for the time you spend at work
and
the way to maximize it so you got career
questions i need a
job questions well ken is here to help
with that and he's going to comment on
everything we do here today as well so
we're uh welcoming you in the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two
five so can this from forbes car
shoppers
on limited budgets can't get a break the
average transaction price for a new
vehicle is expected to rise to a record
38 255 dollars in may
according to jd power sending many
consumers looking for bargains on used
car lots no such luck the combination of
high demand and high wholesale prices
dealers pay to acquire inventory has led
to record high prices for
used cars toby russell co-ceo
at onlineusedvehiclemarketplaceshift.com
told forbes
the surge in used vehicle demand is
causing bizarre bizarre behavior
in the form of used car prices
appreciating
given the strong demand for consumers
the tight supply situation it seems
likely that used
vehicle prices already at all time highs
will continue to rise there's a silver
lining for those looking to trade in
their current vehicles
vehicles demand such as pickup trucks
crossovers suvs are bringing top dollar
and uh the amount paid on a site right
now is increasing 15 to
20 percent in some cases 30 percent
over the last year for the same used car
first time in history used cars have
gone up in
value well they haven't over a period of
a year but that same exact vehicle
all caused by the covet economic
disruption
yep uh people in factories not making
cars that's right
also i read about people not in
factories making cars
that's right well i also saw that be
because travel was
literally almost suspended that rental
car companies are a big source of used
cars
as well because they'll order cars from
manufacturers
they'll rent them to folks like us and
then after a certain point they'll sell
them back
and that becomes a part of the used car
inventory as well so you have two things
manufacturing as a whole
also orders from uh carmel companies so
it's really fascinating but i will tell
you this
i am in the market uh i can't even
believe i'm saying this dave my oldest
is going to be 16 in november so i'm
already beginning to look
just to see is there something right now
that i could jump on and get it
get a great deal put it in the garage
and for him and so i've been looking a
lot
just a direct to consumer uh facebook
marketplace is a great option there
there's all kinds of auto trader
and so outside the dealer i still see in
fact i spent a good time this weekend a
good amount of time looking there still
are great deals
if you're buying directly uh from
someone else
but to the dealers there's no question
the prices are up i see that
yeah and so the other thing that's
happened was
um i bought a used car last week and i
bought it at market
it didn't pay it was not up um took a
little
work though yeah and i actually looked
at the new version of that car
and uh there's such a shortage on it
that dealers are charging
20 000 over sticker for that particular
car
and uh now it's an expensive car but
they're adding a premium on it
on a on a new car because they they gave
me a quote on the new one and i'm like
uh dude i buy it invoice and guys like
not today you don't
right and not right now you don't even
sir across town the same brand is
selling these for twenty thousand over
sticker he said well i'll tell you a
sticker and i went ah i think we're
gonna go used
so i bought a used car and so uh but
it's uh uh
man i mean it the this disruption
and it's just like the new housing like
the new housing market
is screwed up and so it's screwing up
the used housing market and then people
go cray-cray
and they get the chasing stuff and get
the fever and it's like oh god oh god
i'm not going to get what i want
it's like a little kid on the cereal
aisle having a hissy fit
and then they over pay for stuff and so
um
yeah i used vehicles uh are there's a
shortage
and um definitely and there's a shortage
for
uh uh the new because there's a shortage
on new
because the factories were not dialed up
and it's gonna take a little while for
it to catch up so it's like it's gonna
take a little while for lumber
supply demand to catch up right now
lumber's selling for more than gold
it's unbelievable it's true and drywall
i've talked to a builder friend of mine
brought sheets of drywall yeah explode
everything
plywood the glue going into plywood
there's a shortage on
they're saying it's going to go up 4x
before it comes back down but it'll come
back down and these used cars will as
well
yeah so plenty but the good news is if
you're out there and you like just
decided i'm going to get out of debt
and you're like i've got to get rid of
this really stinking overpriced
i bought too much car yeah you know i
got a thirty thousand dollar car
you know twenty eight thousand or oh
thirty two thousand on it this is a
great time
it is it really is a great time to move
down in car
uh it's a great time to get rid of a car
yeah that you that you're trapped in
so that's the good news i'm curious to
know what the trade-in value is how much
it's gone up because traditionally
that's
way way lower than what you can get if
you sell it yourself yeah
you know the other parts of this article
which i didn't read uh but the man
mannheim is the largest wholesaler the
auction houses
that wholesale to the dealers and um
they're seeing across the board about a
10 to a 15
bump wow and uh so that's that's and
then
of course that's of a used car going
across the
dealer auction dealer puts that back on
his lot
and um you know they're not in the
business to lose money so they're gonna
be marking it up that much so
we're seeing this uh the the i i
knew there were going to be shortages
because of covid we talked about that at
this time last year because these
factories all just shut down
and it took them forever to come back
um and you knew there were going to be
shortages but what i didn't for some
reason i didn't i was dumb i
should have been obvious i did not see
the price increases as a result
because it creates a shortage and drives
prices up simple supply demand curve
stuff
and you know you get into that and uh
but you're right the um
the uh rental car companies
hertz it owns dollar that sponsors the
dollar car rental studio so we've had
discussions with them
i didn't realize until we were
sponsoring them and we were actually
talking to them at this time last year
because no one's renting cars
and so they're all screwed they're all
going into bankruptcy they're all you
know right on the teetering on the edge
and what they did was they just sold off
half of their inventory
liquidated these used cars like crazy
they dumped them on the market
well now the market's gone the other way
and now they can't get the new cars
and so it's gone back the other way so
they a lot of rental car companies have
a shortage
of inventory to rent to you oh we see
that all the time it's not unusual
very normal it really is interesting and
hertz is the third largest car dealer in
america
massive yeah that's amazing well you
know it's like you said dave it's like
we had all this
extra supply but we burned through it
and now the factories are trying to
catch back up so it's going to be this
way for a while
i created a new thing as you were
talking either msrp
now it's iiwii it is what it is
you like that so don't buy a new car
anyways we don't tell you to buy a new
car unless you unless you've got it and
then some
but now it's the time to stay away yeah
yeah just just
here's the plan not right now yeah i
don't need it that bad
don't need it that bad this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle is my co-host today
as we talk about your life and your
money the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five joel is
in dallas hi joel how are you
dave i'm doing great sir uh good
afternoon to you and ken i want to say
thank you so much for what you guys do
every day it's important to
a lot of folks out here that are trying
to better their lives and figure stuff
out so thank you well thank you sir how
can we help today
so here's my question we're on baby step
four and
um we i've got a 401k question the
company that i work for
does a very generous uh match
every year it's a profit sharing it's
not actually a match and it can range
between
10 and 15 of my total salary
not sure what it's going to be every
year it's not set in stone kind of
fluctuates
uh right now we are putting 15 into the
401k the traditional 401k every year
good um and have been for the last three
or four years so
we're looking good but my question is
this do i need to be
according to the baby steps do i need to
be putting that much in
given what my company is also
contributing and then second part is do
i need to be looking at
adding the 401k roth option in as well
in addition to or separate well if you
change your 401k will either be
traditional or it will be roth
and it's better for it to be roth and so
i would change it to roth from this
point forward now the matching portion
that they give you
cannot be roth it will be traditional
by law okay uh the matching portion does
not affect our baby step four baby step
four is you
put in 15 of your income
if you get gravy on the biscuit extra
gravy on the biscuit caught a match
that's just that much more wealth you'll
have but i don't depend
on them at all the point of the baby
steps is you are controlling your
destiny
and so you put in 15 if they match if
you have a match you certainly take that
match
and so matches better than roth is
better than traditional
that's the order of attack the rock
paper scissors so to speak
and um so yeah switch it to a roth
and you put in 15 which it sounds like
you are
and you just continue to do that uh can
so the in the old days the
um like when i first started this show
30 years ago
uh still at that time
a lot of companies had the traditional
pension plans now 78
of companies have done away with pension
plans they don't have them anymore
and so it's pretty much a roth
or a 401k or an ira
you're gonna do your own thing and
you're gonna do it through your company
and uh the that's the bad news the good
news is a lot of them match
over 70 of the companies do match
because they don't do the pensions
anymore
yeah why did they pull that was it did
it come down to taxes for companies or
is it too much to manage
why the shift from i didn't know that
number i wrote it down because that was
that was really shocking to me that that
that many companies aren't doing pension
plans
why would they do away with them well
they're super expensive
they're super regulated to manage their
pain in the
uh and because can you think about it i
mean you have a team member that
joins you at 40 at uh 60 they retire
and you now manage this pension for them
for the next 25
years yeah it's too much time and money
and so it just becomes
very cumbersome and with regulations on
them they didn't perform they don't
perform that well
they're not allowed to invest the way
that i would invest or the way i teach
people to invest so they don't
make it they don't make a good rate of
return and so
uh but it's bad for the individual
because now you the only way you have
money in your 401k is you have to put
money in the 401k
it's good for the individual though
because the 401k is yours yep
and the pension is not if the company
goes broke it's an asset of theirs you
could lose the
you know the old story the mind the mind
closed up papa lost his pension that's
right you know and so because the
the pension was not his it was an asset
on the books of
the mining company that went broke and
so they lost it
now that doesn't happen as much but with
the regulations and the insurance and
stuff we've got now
but the union mismanaged the pension and
frittered it away you know these are
real stories that have happened to real
people when it's a 401k the company goes
broke it doesn't touch your 401k because
it's not in their name it's in your name
yeah you know accessing it with a broke
company with the hr
department closed down maybe a bit of a
cumbersome thing but the money is still
there it didn't leave
and so you you are controlling your own
destiny
you're responsible for it and that's
both a blessing and a curse
that's right because look just like it
is when everything that we're
responsible for we have to actually step
up and
man up woman up and get her done miranda
is with us in charleston west virginia
hey miranda how are you
great how are you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
so my husband and i were working on baby
step two
we're going to zell intense and we're
trying to we're looking at our numbers
trying to figure out how to get our
payments to go down
um we have a car it's a ford cmax
of 2004 and kelley blue book has offered
us
10 000 um we owe 21 000
on it and that loan right now has a 5.9
interest rate
yeah so what is this car really worth
is kelly blue look shooting you that low
are you financing negative equity from
the last deal into this one
um no uh we owe 21 000 on it and they're
offering us 10 000.
i know what they're all i heard that
part that's ridiculous
so i'm guessing the car is worth 15 and
they're trying to steal it from you
probably um it's in pretty good
condition
it's 2004. it's a it's a
hybrid did you finance negative equity
were you in the hole when you wrote
trade it in
yes okay so some of this hole is from
the other car
okay so you need to do some more
research and find out what the car is
really worth because
uh if a wholesaler kelly i didn't even
know kelly blue will bought cars but
if they do i'm sure they do and um
if a host they're buying it at wholesale
because they're going to resell it for a
profit
which means that you put it on the
market we're just talking about that
coming into the show
you're going to put the thing on the
market for full value so check
kellybluebook.com not counting this and
just look up of the value do an
appraisal on the car you can go to
edmunds.com as well
i women's car guys and pull up and say
private sale
if i put the thing on facebook
marketplace or neighborhood
marketplace or whatever these things are
that are out there
and you know uh craigslist and people
still do that and so on
uh i don't know is craig dead he could
be dead but um
but anyway that that's uh um you know so
along along those lines you you're gonna
sell the thing trader i know trader.com
you can use
and i sell it direct like ken's out
there looking for a car for his son he
talked about that a minute ago
and so yeah you're going to probably
find that car's worth
13 15 something like that it's probably
not worth 10.
10 sounds insanely yeah yeah i have to
know the mileage on that but you can get
a really good value on that
very easily multiple sites and you could
you could really
hone in on the condition of the car and
i think you get the most
as you possibly can for that because
right now as we said an opening segment
people are your car is competing against
the dealers who are selling
used cars at a premium so if you sell it
actually at market value
you're going to be very competitive a
lot more attractive than there's a
shortage
so yeah definitely definitely make sure
you have your values right
so miranda a good rule of thumb is this
in a negotiation which selling a car is
a negotiation
buying a car negotiation he with the
most information
wins he with the most
patience wins
and he or she with the most options
wins i don't need to sell i got lots of
options
i don't have to sell it i'm not
desperate okay so you got walk away
power
you find out every detail about what
every car like that at every site is
selling for and you become a dad gum
expert on the used car market around
that particular car
information he with the most information
and then you just slow your butt down
you don't get the fever people get
emotionally
like like they had people when they sell
stuff they just they get emotionally
like it's already gone
in their minds and so now they have to
give it away
no no just just plan on keeping it a
while
and be a little hard to get along with
when you're selling it you know come on
now
maximize this asset you need the money
you're broke
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey
mikel is with us in seattle hi michelle
how are you
i'm good how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
well um i have a question that i i feel
like is probably splitting here but i
wanted to know what you would advise
we currently have a 20-year fixed-rate
mortgage and i'm wondering if we should
finance down to a 15.
not for that reason only if you get a
better interest rate
because if you take a 20 and you
calculate what the 15 payment is and you
just pay that much extra it'll pay off
magically in 15.
sure so you don't have to refinance to
do that so
what is the interest rate currently
it's 375 and i talked to churchill and
they said they could get it down to 275.
okay what's your loan balance uh 235
okay so one percent saving is 2 350
bucks a year right
mm-hmm and if it costs you five thousand
dollars to refinance you get your money
back in
two years if it costs you seven thousand
dollars refinance you get your money
back in three years
so you don't make any money until you
get your money back
okay so are you going to be in the house
a while yeah
for a long time we planned okay all
right i probably would refinance it and
while you're at it
put it on a 15. but you don't need to re
if let's say you had a two seven
let's say you had a three percent
20-year mortgage
i would tell you just sit on it and pay
extra
okay you don't need to go to the
refinance cost to pay it off early
you just pay extra and it'll pay off
early but you refinance your refinance
if you can save
not sending them as much money as you
used to
do you know as you used to send them and
so um
you know there's gonna send them 2 350
less
per year for the next many many years
until you pay the thing off
one percent savings per year yeah so i'm
refinancing that if you're staying
and while you're at it do it to a 15.
charlie's in los angeles hi charlie
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call really appreciate it what's up
i am a small business owner out in
california
and it's been luckily a pretty rapidly
growing company
over the past six years and i'm dealing
with an employee of mine who is my
general manager i think has a bit of a
spending addiction
which is making me kind of wonder if i
need to
do all the ideas from a raise or if it's
best just to let him
go when that time comes um
if i can give you a bit of a background
on this gentleman he's in his mid-30s
three kids works full-time for me 80
hours a week he's a great asset to the
company
and um he's in this management position
for just over a year
80 hours a week
um 40 hours a week my apologies oh i'm
on the bike
yeah sorry 40 hours a week okay um now
the issue
is that he left my company before when
he was a warehouse packer
he came back and he worked up to his
management role but since then he has
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
i estimate conservatively in cars
and like automotive toys um he kind of
mentions and complains about money and
stuff but not really in like
a i'm expecting a raise type thing i try
to give him raises organically without
him asking
toward good work what's he made
he makes 45k a year okay
and he just kind of casually in
conversation asked me
if he could start leaving earlier monday
through friday to come in a bit on
saturdays so that he could work a second
job
and just because he has left the company
previously
i just kind of wonder you know i'm not
going to plan letting him go but if he
does ultimately say that
he wants to leave should i try to keep
them around
or focus on my younger staff who are who
have their potential and don't have as
much
how many times how many team members do
you have total
right now we have 15. okay cool okay
yeah the question i have for you charlie
is forget
the finance issues is this guy
a great leader for you or at least a
good leader with tremendous potential
let's set aside just for a moment your
concerns about his spending and him
asking around about a raise
is he a quality team member that you
think uh if he's healthy
you could develop him even further up
so the thing about my small company is
that it's all been a learning experience
kind of for all of us
he didn't really have any managerial
experience but he's been doing a great
job of learning
but what i really value about him more
than anything else is that he cares
about
my company treats it like it's his own
and i feel like does genuinely want to
see the company do well
well i gotta tell you that right there
to me is one of the greatest
characteristics of somebody that they
care deeply about your company and so
he's
he's unhealthy financially and i i would
sit down with him and have a man-to-man
but come at it not from a judgmental
standpoint to say hey here's what's
going on
i don't have all the facts here's what i
think i know
help me fill in the blanks and here's
why i'm bringing this up
i care about you because you care about
this company you've done a great job and
you've learned
and you've grown and you're mentioning
some things here and there why do you
need more money
here's what a development plan might
look like and here's how you'll keep
getting raises and
share a vision for him and see where
he's at financially and see if you can
help him and pour into him and
and take care listen i'd get him
financial peace i'd put him through it
and coach him up if he's willing to do
that show him how if he gets his
spending habits under control
how it will change his entire life
you know i'd be willing to have that
conversation if i were you
because of what you just said about this
guy i think he's worth investing in now
i think you got to have a point where
you get to where you say all right i've
invested
and i've coached and and and now it's up
to him and if you feel like it's too big
of a divide he's not going to get there
and you feel like he can no longer be
the employee that you need
then you move on but i wouldn't try to
anticipate him leaving i think that's
managing
leading out of fear versus being
proactive
so when we were doing entree leadership
when we were doing ontario leadership a
couple weeks ago
out in dallas um pat lincione said there
is no such thing
as any kind of leadership except servant
leadership
and so if you're going to lead him then
you need to care enough to serve him
and how are you serving him uh you got
to sit down and go
dude forty five thousand dollar income
hundred fifty thousand dollars in toys
you're doing
fouchy math here this doesn't work okay
you can't this doesn't work
you know you're not in congress you have
to stop this
for your sake you can't win doing this
and i love you and so i'm just trying
i'm just looking at you man-to-man
friend a friend and going
i'm gonna serve you well and so
you know i've had and our leadership
team have had conversations with people
inside of our organization over the
years
uh almost on a weekly basis someone we
sit down with and say listen i love you
too much
to just not tell you this you gotta you
gotta know
this is this right here is killing you
this is hurting you and and so because
here's the thing
you're serving him then what you got to
do is you got to go okay if he has a
lack of judgment over there
how long before that lack of judgment
regardless of how much he cares
enters into our organization if his
critical thinking skills have got him
this far in debt i mean he's going to
start making stupid butt decisions at
work too
and so we got to get him off the stupid
butt train and get him on the train
where he can learn and that's just
loving the guy well that's serving him
um when i serve my children and they're
growing up
it means i teach them how to behave and
function in society
it doesn't mean the inmates run the
asylum
uh because i love my kids enough to
serve
i'm gonna serve you i'm gonna make sure
you know how to drive a dadgum car
before i give you the keys i'm going to
make sure you know how to behave and
say yes ma'am and yes sir and thank you
and gratitude
and you know all you know that kind of a
thing and so you're
serving someone by loving them well yeah
and by having hard difficult
conversations with them yeah you got to
sit down in this situation you say hey
you're looking for a second job
that means more work hours a week more
time away from your family
and this is all because you're not
showing discipline over here and when
you show them you're teaching you're
guiding you're instructing
shoot them straight i'll pay for you to
go i'll pay for your ramsey plus
membership and you go
you know you you uh that's what you tell
him and you go
i'll walk with you and i'll coach you
and because i think you've got
huge rock star potential as a leader
yeah because of your passion for this
place
and i really want to pour into you and
lift you up yeah
and you can set a model in place then on
how you lead people for the rest of your
life there
really cool question charlie you got a
good heart man this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
[Music]
825-5225 matt is with us in springfield
missouri
hey matt welcome to the show how can we
help hey dave thanks for taking my call
sure um so um long story short here
my wife and i bought a house in 2012 uh
at about 160 000
and we spent the last eight years paying
off our house and we just did that last
year
in july and now my wife's wanting to
move again
and because her office got closed down
during the uh kovid pandemic
and she ended up working remotely from
home now permanently
and so i'm having trouble coming to
terms with wanting to possibly take on
another mortgage
and so i'm kind of needing some advice
on how
i should handle this uh um okay so your
current home is worth what
we bought the home for 160 in 2012 and
right now it's probably worth about 280.
okay and what's wrong with the house you
have now
uh nothing wrong with it she just one
she doesn't like the layout and two
there's no office space for her we're in
a home like she works from the kitchen
table
and we have you know kids and everything
and uh it
gets noisy and she can't you know do
client calls and stuff like that because
it's
too distracting okay so why couldn't you
buy
a 280 000 home
with a different layout and that had an
office
well we've been looking and uh we
haven't found anything
in our area uh of that price and uh with
the layout
because you haven't looked in that
neighborhood you've been looking in
those expensive neighborhoods
you could say that yeah no i'm sure of
it i mean
you know yeah that's the logo you're
looking at the wrong neighborhood if you
want to stay out of debt right well i i
do want to stay out of debt i don't
well why are you looking in the
neighborhood that has debt
uh that's a good question but uh the the
area has just shot up so high that
you know well then yours should have
been shot up
i mean a 280 000 home in springfield
missouri's no slouch dude
that's a that's a decent house and you
could have a differently configured home
that included a different layout and
config
included that for that same money and
just swap houses
yeah but what we're doing is we're using
all this other bs as an excuse to move
up in-house
that's really what it comes down to yeah
yeah i guess you could say that yeah
i mean i want a different kitchen that's
got like 70 000 more worth of crap in it
and i'm using this i'm working at the
kitchen table whining as my excuse to go
into that again
so where in the process did you all lose
or did she lose the vision of being debt
free on your home
is worth it uh
well i think it's just been over the
course of since she's had to work from
home
the constant interruptions with
kids being in the area and her trying to
handle phone calls and get work done
and um go renter an office
yeah we've we've talked about that but
we we do pay for a private school as
well
for our children and
we haven't been able to justify the cost
of getting a rental office or her
her business did have her set up to go
to a rental office's office spaces
and then they got rid of that option
what kind of work is she doing
she's a hr consultant so she's on the
phone
eighty percent of the day yeah she's
handling she does a compensation mail
analysis uh executive analysis who's
watching the kids when they're not in
school like how many kids are running
around
we have two kids and it'll usually be me
watching them but i i do shift work so
i'll
one week i'm working nights the next
week i'm working evenings so i have a
crazy work schedule i work weekends yeah
well let me just tell you something by
yourself let me say something dave's
absolutely right you too
this is a relationship thing you guys
got to sit down and and re
re-establish the why why did we do all
this for eight years
what was the whole purpose of this and
you know this is a pretty easy solve
number one you're living in a hundred
sixty thousand dollar area so today's
point the two days
yeah i know well i'm saying that's what
they were yeah that's what they bought
at yeah and then so there's a couple
neighborhoods up so i think it's unsafe
it's not like schools are awful so i
think this big bad world you're in
the other thing is is that you know she
can work at the coffee shop or something
just
you know and make phone calls and step
out or do whatever i just i just think
this idea that we got to move somewhere
for her to have a place to work besides
the kitchen table
i i just think that's a relationship
thing where you guys have to
re-establish the why behind this
and then say okay we're willing to do
this but we're not willing to
go beyond the 280. and if we can't get
happy with something for 280
cash then uh you have to come up with
another solve until you save up enough
to be able to do something you want i
mean what's your household income
175 a year go rent an office
yeah okay today
okay and then if you want to trade
houses trade houses but that off listen
the
tail's wagging the dog here you're
making a bad financial decision for a
temporary situation
right yeah working at the kitchen table
is not the way it's gonna be for the
next decade
right she's not gonna be the kitchen
table for a decade and you don't you
don't go
buy a house uh because of something that
happened with covid uh these are you
know
i i do not know when she'll be back at
work or when they'll be funding the
office but you make
plenty of money and so for you know what
four or five hundred bucks you can go
rent a single office in one of these
office suites
and just you know she can plan herself
down there and then she's got a work
environment that's reasonable
and then if you want to trade houses for
a better layout that's fine
you could guys can do whatever you want
you got a lot of excuses for a guy that
called in wanting help not to do this
and i'm just telling you don't do it
there's no chance
no chance that i'm going into that in
this situation
none this is all a bunch of i want it
and i'm a little bit uncomfortable and
i'm sorry you're uncomfortable
i'm sorry she's uncomfortable whoopi
don't put yourself back into a mortgage
over that you finally got yourself free
man
remember what it was like having that
thing hanging around your neck don't go
back into the noose don't stick your
head back in there man
don't put your foot in a bear trap again
them things hurt man
don't do it don't do it please please
don't do it
and and you know but you you you know is
there a valid
part of this that she's trying to do
business in an
unprofessional situation yeah go around
an office and do it tomorrow
that's what i would do in your situation
i'm not going into debt
for an office in your home over
now is literally these uh closets that
are offices it's like a new thing
uh you look it up online i'm not kidding
you where people are turning closets
into miniature offices
geez we can at least do that no
i'm not going in the closet
not a chance she makes 175 000. i agree
i'm trying to give him a non-rent option
i just you know there's another place
besides the kitchen table
but i agree with you you can go get an
office yeah yeah
but here here's the thing it's a vis
where there is no vision the people
perish
if you work really hard to get out of
debt because you believe
that your life is so much better being
debt-free you have so much higher
probability of building wealth by being
debt-free
you would never go back but you quit
believing that somewhere along the line
and we're willing to trade that for the
inconvenience of the current situation
and i'm not willing to trade it no the
the the difference is that
when we went broke and lost everything i
said never again and i meant it
never again are these bozos gonna have
their thumb on my neck
never again is american express gonna
call my house unless it's a wrong number
never again there's not a chance i am
not going back
there's not anything you people can do
to scare me enough there's nothing you
can do to make me mad enough
there's not anything you can do to make
me greedy enough
passionate enough to go into debt the
borrower is slave to the lender
and i am free and i am never
going back it's easy for me to say and
and i can't imagine you and stacy having
that conversation to be any different
no yeah it's look
every time that you allow your emotions
to drive you
then then you lose sight of decisions
that you have made
many you know what i mean and your
critical thinking skills critical
thinking is gone
and i feel this i feel this i feel this
and in this situation you made a great
recommendation
they can upgrade and still be
mortgage-free yeah
it's easy
it's not a bad it's not like not
enough enough enough that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five anders in washington
d.c
hey andrew how are you good dave how are
you
better than i deserve what's up
so uh we've been working the plan for
three years
um we paid off just under a hundred
thousand dollars in debt and then the
next two years spent
uh saving up and obviously doing the
emergency fund
and we did the 3b we saved almost 200
000
we put down money on the house then we
have our emergency fund in place
great so we're looking to kind of do the
four five and six
perfect um now the 15
got that that's great we start investing
in retirement
and now the question i have is the 529
should i do that or a separate broker's
account that's not a traditional 529
specifically with our income
and then we don't know if our kids are
or are not going to go to college
okay well uh
uh what is your household income
so right now it's a little over 200 but
kind of projected to go up okay well to
start with no one knows that their kind
of kids are going to go to college but
we're for sure
know that if they don't have the money
it's going to be harder
so a 529 grows tax-free i love keeping
the government's hands off the growth
it can be transferred to a sibling it
can be transferred to a parent
another family member it can be
transferred if they
don't use it if they got scholarships
they can you can pull from a 529
the equivalent amount of the scholarship
with no taxes
tax-free growth and so yeah i'm doing a
529.
i'm not going to over fund it if you
have concerns i'm not going to put 200
000
in there but but i'm definitely going to
put 40 or 50 60 grand in there and
depend on the age of the kid
and maybe even more but uh uh
and let it grow you know a brokerage
account
infers that you're buying and selling
stocks and you don't need to be doing
that
especially for your kids college so i
don't want that much risk
i just use good growth stock mutual
funds and a tax-free growth in a 529
and and you choose the mutual funds and
you choose to move them around that's
the type of 529 you want
we're very specific about that in our in
financial peace university and in the
total money makeover but
yeah just you know you don't have to
overdo it
but uh don't under do it either and
overthink it
about whether your kid's going to
college or not
interesting so when we start the show 30
years ago the assumption was everybody
wanted their kid to go to college
and now they don't yeah and increasingly
becoming the case
but also point out here that these 529
plans that money can be used for
non-traditional college education as
well so trade schools
that's anything from tech schools i mean
you can use that and and so you're
seeing more and more opportunities for
people to get qualified to do the work
they want to do so it's not
like you're you're being unwise but you
can use it for their
private school when they're one k
through 12. you can
that's exactly right so it's still the
best option yeah and keeping the
government's hands off the taxes and not
screwing around with the money with
single
stock trades acting like you and your
buddy eating a biscuit at cracker barrel
have a clue what's going on
don't do it don't do it man and just get
in there in some mutual funds those guys
are on the mutual fund they're
coming coming to work in a car longer
than your house they know what's going
on
so it's it's not perfect but uh that's
where all of my kids college money was
so i'm not being hypocritical
uh and so yeah i'm doing a 529. you can
use private school
while they're uh k-12 you can do any
kind of post-secondary education there's
all kinds of stuff you can use it for
legally and it keeps the government's
hands off of it and so you know if you
put twenty thousand dollars in there and
it grows to eighty or a hundred
that's eighty thousand dollars with no
taxes on it
i like that i like that a lot better
than screwing around with it in a
brokerage account that's right and a lot
of options
tons of options uh gustavo is with us
in tucson i mispronounced that how do
you pronounce your name
sir i did say it you nailed it well i
didn't mess it up
hillbilly spanish is just a hard thing
dude i'm just saying
so what's up man uh well i kind of had
like a weird question that
i'm on baby step i'm finishing up baby
step three next month just to give you a
heads up of where i'm at
and um i want to get a toy i had one
when i was in debt
but i want to make sure it's kind of
weird because my vehicles
aren't worth too much and the toy that
i'm looking into which is the rzr razor
run they run about 15 000 news and
that's more than my vehicles
combined but i'm we're kind of happy
with our vehicle so that's where my
question is kind of
is it weird that my toy would be more
expensive than my vehicles even though
we would be in a position to buy it
cash yes all right
i mean it's which it's weird you know
it's weird that's why you're asking
right you already knew it's weird but
it's cool
they're neat they're neat vehicles man
you talk about that the um
is it the can-am make that who makes
that the
razer does uh polaris polaris makes it
yeah that's right
yeah yeah i've got some friends down at
cabo that have
have them and they all ride up the beach
at cabo those those things are very cool
they look they look neat too man and
they will haul butt they they're fun
yes so uh yeah and you're you're in
tucson so you're doing like desert
desert action with the thing huh right
yeah
i mean i could make it all the way to
phoenix i'm sure yeah i bet you could
yeah it's they're they're very cool it's
a cool vehicle
i i kind of want i kind of want one
myself but um
anyway the yeah uh
your cars are uh your your daily driver
transportation your family depends on
those your
income is dependent upon those um
and so yeah the uh uh you know a a
snowmobile a sea doo
a boat uh a razor should not be
worth more than your cars uh
it's just kind of a common sense thing
it's not really a financial thing
uh so right all it says is that you're
probably not quite there yet
that would be my opinion and of course
you made the mistake of asking so
i'll give you my opinion but the um
yeah that's i i mean you've got you got
a toy in your house
i do but it was a gift to you on that it
was and as you know i'm cash flowing the
renovation of it yeah
he has a classic car yeah got a 72
convertible karma gea
uh found an old guy uh in the hood that
loves working on him and so he's gonna
help me put the carpet kit in and
just do a little bit at a time because
we have kids in school and and
other things and and so you just have to
go at the speed of cash like you said
when we built this place and so i got
the exterior done
still a little bit more to do and it
still looks pretty sweet it looks sweet
but yeah you have to kind of what's the
ratio on that i mean understand what
he's saying he's like well i got baby
step three now he needs to get the baby
step four
actually put that in the budget then he
needs to begin to save for something
like that yeah and you
you know i i and i don't know that i
have a rule
and i'm just kind of sitting here
thinking on the fly but
right really you're if you're if your
boat is
eighty thousand dollars and your cars
are ten thousand dollars that just seems
to
seem right you know and so if your
razor's fifteen thousand and your cars
are five thousand that seems backwards
yeah
you know and it but those razors are
very cool they're
very yeah i think he may have talked you
into buying wise i don't
need one right i don't know why but i'm
probably just because it has a motor and
it goes because
it's fast it goes wood and wooden there
you go man so i've probably got a loud
muffler i can make a redneck muffler on
it oh sure
you redneck anything up you know that
there you go
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five if you're tired of feeling
stuck with your money
like you'll never get out of debt or
save enough it doesn't have to be that
way you can get a ramsey plus
membership that includes the ever dollar
budgeting app the world's best budgeting
app it includes
financial peace university where you can
go through the class
learn step by step how to get out of
debt like millions
literally of people have done
when you budget you get intentional with
your money you get a clear path
you start working it you're gonna make
progress you're gonna make it fast
you can start budgeting you can start
making these steps free
starting today with a free trial of
ramsey plus text
trial to 33 789
text trial two three three
seven eight nine ld is with us
in indianapolis hi l.d welcome to the
ramsey show
i did listen to you for a long time uh
my wife and i are
getting ready to have a first baby hey
when's he coming
anytime you know all right good for you
yeah yeah pretty excited uh we got
some pretty told goals for the future
and so we'd like to
we're trying to grow our income as much
as possible
trying to decide if now would be a good
time for her to
maybe advance her career and become a
dental hygienist
she's an assistant right now but it put
about 10 to 12 dollars an hour on her
pay
caveat to that would be we one of our
goals is for her to
be able to stay at home and be a bigger
part of our business
within the next 10 12 years or so and so
just trying to decide if it's
if it's justifiable i guess interesting
so
what would she do in the business if she
stayed home with the baby and babies
potentially
and worked in the business what would
she be doing
uh uh
full-time i'm a farmer and uh
so you know she she's uh she's also a
pretty good bookkeeper
and things like that and so okay uh my
mom take my mom takes care of a lot of
that right now but you know in the
future
okay so so she saves you money by doing
the bookkeeping that you're paying
someone else to do or she's replacing
mom
she would probably be you know doing a
lot of what my mom does
okay so you have to weigh all right she
wants to be home uh sounds like that's
what both of you want versus she now
continues to work and there's the cost
of the schooling the cost of getting
qualified to become that dental
hygienist
and you're looking at ten to twelve 12
an hour so you start weighing
opportunity cost
with the emotional costs and i think
that if it's stacey and i we're going to
sit down together in
the old-fashioned grandpa and grandma
conversation the pros and cons of both
of those
so which way does her heart lead the
most which if things were just
has she wanted them forget about the
money equation and making more money and
all the benefits that come with that
what does her heart want to do
oh she she definitely wants to be able
to stay at home at some point
all right so why are you back and forth
on this where were you at the start of
this phone call
uh like i said we're we just we've got
some
some things we'd like to accomplish and
her her incomes
it helps helps with getting there what
does she make
she makes about 30 right now okay so
that this would put her at about 40.
uh hygienists are in our area are in
that 50s
yeah 50s 50s okay i mean okay and so
um what does hygienist school cost
uh well we live in the middle of nowhere
and so it's about thirty thousand but
it'd be a pretty good
a lot of travel time involved with that
too with a new baby
two and a half years right it takes two
and a half years
yeah so we have time and money here
right right yeah this is more than just
working for
uh working uh
with the baby at home this is uh two and
a half years of training
in it and by by the way during that time
she's not working right
it'd be pretty tough it'd be pretty
tough on her yeah yeah
yeah so it's costing you 30 a year
in income and it's costing you 30
000 over two and a half years and she's
traveling and gone
so that after two and a half years she
works for six years making twenty
thousand dollars more
i mean you're gonna she's gonna make
money on this transaction
but it doesn't sound like it's worth it
yeah
yeah that's been our back and forth yeah
it sounds like by the time
i mean if she was going to do it for the
rest of her life and make an extra 20
000
a year and loved it and it was the
long-term goal
that might then the equation starts to
work
mathematically yeah but right now you're
not going to get enough
of her increased income before she's
willing or before she's able to come
home i think you start figuring out what
she could do
from home to create an income
while she's helping you with the farm
stuff and they're with the babies i
think maybe we look at shifting that i
bet you she could come up with a side
gig
like a christy wright business boutique
idea um
i mean if it's just selling stuff on
ebay i don't care what it is yeah and
then
it may be streamlining operations on the
farm remember we're saving money that's
more money in our pockets certainly to a
farmer
you know the thing that point out here
uh is ld is that her heart
is not in it if i heard on there that
her heart
she wanted to be a dental hygienist what
she's always wanted to do she loves it
loves it loves it but she also wants to
be a mom for a season
then i think this is an investment and a
sacrifice that you figure out how to do
but i'm going to tell you with that kind
of schedule the schooling
you're losing your income as it is
that's going to create all types of
sacrifices and a squeeze
and and when you don't have the drive
the juice for something
i'm going to tell you it makes it really
really difficult and it can put you
behind
emotionally not just financially
daniel's in columbia south carolina hi
daniel welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up all right so um
i'm in baby step six um i'm 27
and my wife is 25. um basically my mom
reached out to me um
asking for help um she had a lease
a and if you want to pay it off
on basically it ended up um
the lease ends up this month um and she
asked me
to to borrow uh for me to
to 2k and basically um she asked me not
to tell my wife and obviously
you know we are we have jones account
and also um what's your question
yeah what what's your advice in my
situation i don't do
anything that i can't tell my wife
anything ever
if i'm in a meeting and they say all the
discussion in this meeting has to stay
in this room you can't tell your wife i
get up and leave the meeting
there are no things on this planet that
i can't tell sharon
that is against the law at ramsey world
it will get your throat cut by your wife
while you're asleep dude
you can't be hiding crap from your wife
hello is that right yeah yes i'm sorry i
mean your mom is out of control
where's your dad are they divorced yeah
no they're
they are together they have separate
accounts and actually my dad
let him lend her uh 10k to pay off he
lent his own wife money
yes that's strange
okay so uh mom i can't do anything that
i love you but i can't do anything that
i can't tell my wife and don't ever
suggest that again
because it's not gonna it's not a
profitable conversation for us to have
okay mom can't do that and if you need
uh
two thousand dollars you need to talk to
your husband my dad
and you guys need to work on your
finances and get them get them combined
and get them straightened out
but i i think your mom i think your mom
is trying to hide
all of this from everybody and still
trying to find a way to snake her way
through this
and it's time that the cards are played
faze up on the table mom is getting
ready to be exposed
and needs to be you know needs to be so
she needs to talk to your dad
and she and your dad have got a lot of
work to do but you don't need to get
involved in this son
you just lovingly say no i don't hide
things from my wife and i
really think you need to talk to dad
about this he's got the money and you
guys have the money and
you all need to fix this so sorry
can't do it love you mom love you mom no
chance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the phones in minneapolis
is going to be kristin who says on my
screen kristen you're debt free
congratulations
thank you hi guys hey how much have you
paid off
61 091 and
love it how long did this take 48 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
okay i went back and checked and it was
32 000
to 51 000 and now back down to about 40.
wow so what do you do for a living
i'm an accountant and recently a ramsey
master financial coach
ah okay so starting to get some extra
income that way
yeah very good good for you so what kind
of debt was the 61
000 so a lot of it was medical
just kind of stuff that surgeries
children being born and then just like
once we would accumulate
it it would just hang around and
payments payments payments there was
some personal loans
and a big family loan that we had to do
repairs on our home
okay wow good for you so how much was
the big family lounge
that was was like 22 000.
that was the big one of the whole bunch
that was the big guy hiding in the
closet yeah
gotcha okay so what happened four years
ago that put you on this journey
so my marriage was coming to an end and
that's when we separated our money
and i had always wanted to be debt free
and become an edm
so that was like pedal to the metal
so fresh start after the divorce yep
and um you already knew about our stuff
but you were just now able to do it
because of the
the disagreement in the household before
yeah it was like uh
you know putting on a lot of throttle
and the car is in neutral
now now i actually got some traction
okay good for you all right so you're
going to be an everyday millionaire
that's your future i love that
yeah and what do you tell people when
you're coaching them now that the key to
getting out of debt is because you paid
off 61
000 in four years making 32.
yeah for me there was three
three things and i would say the reason
which is my voice
the plan obviously and then just the
determination
so we just saw a picture of the four
boys right
yep on youtube there good looking family
yeah thanks that's fun you got a lot of
why there
yeah wow for sure
so i i want to ask you when you decide
as you're coming out of this divorce so
that's a painful thing and you decide
all right i'm going to restart reboot do
it the way that i always wanted to do it
you've got those boys as your why every
day looking at them
uh what what fired you up the most
in this process was it the first one the
first the debt that you paid off on the
debt snowball was it just
the boys what was the real driver for
you once you got into the process where
you
begin to experience some momentum
i think i had a lot of little loans
so getting started and getting those
paid off there was a lot of immediate
you know payoff for those and i just
knew what i wanted to give them i didn't
i didn't want a house full of stress
and i wanted to give them a good future
not like just giving them money
but showing them what to do and they
they hold me accountable i got a debit
card mail to me
and i open it up and they're like mom is
that a credit card
[Laughter]
they're always watching me that's great
that's so fun
very cool so they know the rules then
they know what you have to do
oh yeah yeah very very fun
cool so um
how long had you been familiar with our
stuff before your marriage ended
uh quite a while um i think my
folks introduced me to your radio show
and back in like 2010 and then
um i coordinated an fpu starting in 2011
and then i did another one before my
last son was born so i've done a couple
of those
and i was just kind of hooked because
i'm a natural saver
and so once kind of the shackles were
off
and we found a better church that i
wanted to be at and i started tithing
again
and i think dave you had said like a
month ago when you talked about god
throwing open the window of heaven
he sure did in my case because it's like
once you know we were pushing the bike
down the hill everything just kept
piling on
i swear i have food show up in my
freezer that wasn't there
i had a expedition that i think two of
the pictures are like a time lapse
that i got when my son was seven months
old the oldest one
and he's 12 now and i've still got it
it's just about 300 000 miles on it
but stuff just kept being a benefit
there was just kind of blessings from
everywhere
wow can i ask you what did you do to
take go from 32 to 51k
what happened um i my regular job was
not
40 hours so i had a base of that and
then
i did a lot of side accounting work
and then just try to get and i got a
couple more clients and stuff like that
and then i worked for my mom who's a cpa
and i did tax work
at night and just kind of everywhere i
could pull from
yeah that's great very good you're a
hustler yeah you're getting her done
girl
proud of you very very well done good
job who are your biggest cheerleaders
other than your boys
um i would say my parents because
they've been down that road and they've
been debt free for a while
i have a lot of friends i don't have a
lot of naysayer friends i got a lot of
friends who are debt free
or are on their way and then yeah these
these kids i can't say enough about them
because they never complained they knew
what the plan was
they volunteered i don't need a treat we
can save it
so i'm just really proud of what they
have learned and how they keep me
accountable
very cool very cool powerful kristen
what are the boys names
so aiden is 12. gavin is
nine mason is seven
and morgan is four so we're going to try
to coordinate it they're coming in here
they're going to do the screen
all right they've earned it no question
about it very cool
what a great family project we're proud
of you great job we've got a copy of the
legacy journey which is the next
uh chapter in your story as you said
you're going to be an edm an everyday
millionaire you are on your way kiddo
and uh and of course another copy of the
total money makeover which you'll be
able to give to someone and pay it
forward and get somebody else's
journey started with that best-selling
book
so good stuff all right kristen and the
gang
61 000 paid off in 48 months making
32 000 extra side hustles up to 51 part
of that time
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
all right ready boy three two
one
i love that sound yes
that is the sound of a family tree being
changed right there you heard it
yes those boys lived that with her yeah
what a legacy single mom uh
leading modeling the way
i i just you know i'm always blown away
by the stories of everybody we get to
hear
their debt-free journey but certainly uh
you know anthony o'neal and i got to
host a show last week or a single mom
uh making thirty two thousand dollars
same thing same thing
and i i have a special place in my heart
for those ladies yeah step up and do
that we all do it's hard enough to
parent
certainly by yourself and then and then
go through that debt-free journey i want
to point out something dave that i
thought was so heartwarming
you asked her who were her biggest
cheerleaders and she said beyond her
parents
were friends she said they weren't
naysayers they had been on the journey
themselves and i just want to point that
out
that when you decide to live like no one
else you better hang out with people
that are that are on board and will
support you
you become who you hang around with
birds of a feather
you read what they read that's true you
talk like they talk
you um you know you attend church like
they attend church you treat your spouse
like they treat their spouse i mean this
is
this is you become who you hang around
with so choose carefully my friends
choose carefully this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
carol is with us in sacramento hi carol
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can ken and i help
okay i have a question i'm actually a
ranty coach and also an everyday
millionaire
we have three homes that are paid for
and we are also
a co-owner with one of our children due
to due
to a divorce um our question is this
if we sell one of the rental homes we
could net
about 560 000 which is
almost enough to pay off the kids homes
and surprise them
we don't quite have enough we're about
60 k short of paying off both of the
homes
should we do that or should we keep the
house or should we
sell it and put the money in mutual
funds i'm confused you said
kids homes two homes
we have yes two homes
and to adult children okay and we're
we're co-owners
on one of the homes okay but you would
pay it off and
surrender that ownership yes
okay because you're only a co-owner
because you had to bail them out in a
divorce
yes and then my our other kid has his
own home
and um okay so you sell the rental and
it brings 560 000 but you need 620
000 to do this exactly and you don't
have the other cash
we kind of do i just don't know if it's
smart to pull that out of it because we
would we have other funds it's not a
retirement fund i just don't know if
it's smart to do right now
um we're getting eaten alive and capital
gains are paying about 200 000 in
capital gains
so what is your net worth probably about
3 million
okay i would do it but i would only do
it if you pull out enough out of your
other investments
in order to actually do it if you don't
actually pay off the mortgages it kind
of defeats the purpose doesn't it
yeah kind of because from what i
understand in california you can only
gift so much money per year so we may
not be able to do the whole thing
all in one uh you i don't know
california law but in this in the u
the federal taxes there you have a gift
tax limitation that this is well in
excess of
but you can use some of your federal
estate tax exemption called a unified
estate tax credit
and you just have to do it you have to
unified as state tax credit
and you're using some of your federal
exemption
up so when you die you would have used
some of it up already
but you're nowhere near the limits
anyway it's like 20 million so you're
fine
that's what you would do to get rid of
the federal gift tax
i do not know california tax law at all
so you'd want to you want to consult a
tax professional to figure that out
i suspect that that unified estate tax
credit would also apply in california
i i bet you it's aligned with the
federal guidelines this is my guess
i'll be shocked if it's not um but
california does some weird butt stuff to
tax our people so i don't know
um but anyway yeah so uh
your net worth now becomes two and a
half and they have paid for houses the
only other question i've got is
would they commit to never borrowing
money again for anything
yes yeah i wouldn't make it a big deal
but i probably would have like a little
one-page letter in both of them and
their spouses sign it
if we pay off your home you never borrow
money again and so our family tree is
completely changed
never borrow money again for anything
for any reason
yeah ever and by the way you shouldn't
have to if you don't have a house
payment you'll be able to save up and
buy anything you want to buy
yeah yeah that's and just you know we we
bring in a nice
income off of the rent we don't have to
have it so that's kind of my dilemma too
i'm
just like
sorry how old are you guys we're in our
60s
yeah i would do it yes
really yeah okay and pull the other 60k
out of
yes i would not do it unless you're
going to pay them off i mean there's no
point in paying it down
that doesn't do anything you still have
student mortgage so but get rid of the
the debt and have them both sign a
little one-page letter
um just type it up and just talk about
legacy and how you want to change your
family tree and
everybody participates i think that's a
fair trade and then after that you just
don't bring it up and you can't go
managing their finances anymore this is
their life
you don't get to interfere this is a
gift but it's
pr the gift is predicated on the fact
that we're changing our family tree
and that is a fair level of control in
return for the gift
yeah let me ask you on that are you
saying in the letter that they are
committing
the they're just asking the kids to
commit to that they're not going to be
checking
up on them that's what you're getting at
correct there's no strings attached but
it kind of is
well it's a it's a promise yeah i like
that it's just a promise
i promise in return for having my
mortgage paid off to never borrow money
again yeah i think that's fair
that's a family oath so to speak but
it's not a
it's not a legal commitment and no
you're not gonna check up on them once a
year and look at their balance sheets
and
no you're not doing any of that it's
just like you know if they go and
buy a house and put it on a mortgage in
the future you would just look at them
and say you broke your promise
you know that's it that's all it is and
then you just go well that's sad you
broke your promise
because you shouldn't have had to yeah
if you're because the kids are going to
be millionaires pretty quick
oh yeah no question about it they'll be
there very very quickly depending if
they're
if they are you know learning from their
parents model
uh to not borrow and to be generous and
to be investors
they'll get there very very quickly open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five matthews in phoenix hi
matthew how are you
doing well dave yourself better than i
deserve how can we help
uh i have a question about refinancing
we owe about a 131
on the house with about seven years left
of
payments after refinancing about
eight years ago and my wife is going to
be
losing uh going on to full disability
probably within the next six months to a
year and unable to work which will be
cutting our income in
half to have money for medical
expenses would it be smart to refinance
to
lower the house payment to cover
medical expenses in the future what do
you make
uh currently uh 45 from my work
and then with the veteran disability i
collect another
24 000 so about 65
a year nine yeah and the house payment's
about 15.50
okay um what does she make
uh currently about 60 to 70
so after she's what is the nature
what is the nature of her disability
it's a terminal illness that's slowly
debilitating her where she has
chronic fatigue and unable to stay awake
or
work oh my how old is she
uh mid-40s and i'm in my mid-30s
wow i'm sorry man
uh that's a battle we've been going
through but still staying
strong and trying to follow your way as
best as possible to
prepare for the upcoming future of
her health issues
seven years is so fast you're going to
be done i hate to have you walk away
from that
but i would not trade quality of life
if we've got a terminal diagnosis for
anything
so um yeah i probably would con i
probably would consider just because
i don't only want you to have the wiggle
room to make sure you got medical bills
and stuff covered i think you can cover
the house payment i think you could cut
it out and make it
but it might mean that you don't get to
do some things with her that you need to
do
while she can exactly so it was
the out of being debt-free because we
only owe
131 on the house and you're almost there
in seven years oh i hate to have you
lose that
but yeah if you put that on a 15 it will
relax that payment considerable
and uh you can circle back later
and maybe still make it in seven years
or eight years or something you never
know
exactly where this journey is going to
take you but um
yeah i mean you you need to concentrate
on her
okay just wanted to hear from you
because i know always snowball forward
and we've been doing really good the
last seven years after taking your
course
i would love to see you finish it up but
not if it means that
you lose some experiences with the time
you have with her
that's not a that's not a good trade i
i wouldn't but either way is okay
but i just wow heartbreaking i'm sorry
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today
he is the host of the ken coleman show
which is
where you learn all about your career
all about jobs all about how to get them
out about how to find the work
you love and so if you have questions
about career and work he's here to help
and we're here to help you in general so
jump in at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
canal is with us canal is in columbus
ohio
hi canal what's up hi how you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
i had a quick question about
self-banking
with whole term life insurance and
whether it's worth it
if you accrue a cash balance and borrow
against that and pay interest to
yourself or if you should stay away from
that and
keep using a bank yeah um
it's an absolute scam it's a whole life
policy it's not a turn
it's not a term policy it's a whole life
life insurance policy
basically whole life life insurance is
where you pay
20 times more for the same amount of
insurance
and so the extra 95 dollars out of the
hundred dollars
goes into a savings account and um
that you earn very little on after you
finally start to build it up
and then one of the ways they're
pitching it now is the self-banking
concept where you use your own money
which by the way when you have a
checking account you are
using your own money i don't know why
they think that's magical
okay perfect i guess i won't use that no
i i wouldn't use it i would stay
completely away from
the company that is offering it and any
other offerings that they have
because it is a really really bad
product
and it is a scummy way to sell whole
life life insurance which is a scummy
product to start with
but no one sells that stuff anymore
except people no one believes in it or
talks about it positively
except people that are in that business
and this whole thing of
you can borrow your own money why would
i want to borrow my it doesn't even make
any sense dave but this is the power of
marketing
i mean the message here is really look
into stuff i love that people can call
and get advice on this
but really dig into stuff and and and
does it make sense
and if it doesn't make sense why doesn't
it make sense but they put some
wonderful marketing copy on this
yeah so make money from yourself give
you another one it just keeps
yeah isn't that great and you pay and
you pay them interest
right to borrow money from to borrow
your money that you saved up in your
savings you're moving money from your
checking account to put it over there to
them to not even get a good return on it
to get it back it's just
it's mind-numbing it's like moving a
pile of rocks from one side of the yard
to the other
back and forth back and forth back and
forth but and so here's the other one
uh whole life life insurance you can uh
you can use it cash value insurance
grows tax-free
well no it doesn't that's a lie
but here's how they propose that you do
this
you overpay for your insurance by 20
times for all of your life your whole
life that's where it comes from they
take your money your whole life and
finally you have some money in there
let's just say you've got fifty thousand
dollars in there
now if the 50 000
is in excess of what you paid in
and you take it out that is taxable
because there's a game
right yes but not if you borrow it
and so you put money into this
investment now you can borrow
your money that you put in there
back out and pay them interest
but it's tax-free yeah well no kidding
doofus when you go to the bank and
borrow 50
000 they don't charge you taxes on it
it's a debt
yeah of course it's not taxable
debt is not taxable but it's not a
tax-free growth on an investment like a
roth ira or roth 401k right it's not
even on the same planet
yeah it's the same kind of stuff that
he's dealing with there and it's this
whole idea of
but but boy i mean you talk about
i mean they're they're almost as scummy
as the timeshare people
yeah they're almost that scummy yeah
they're almost as scummy as the payday
lenders
they're right up there that's straight
up manipulation what you just laid out
for us
as clear as you could lay it out that's
manipulating people
lying yeah we could call it live dave
ramsey is giving bad advice
because with whole life you could get
tax-free growth
no you can't yeah no you can
borrow your own money
and pay them interest right and borrowed
money is
always tax-free because it's borrowed
right
it's not an actual investment
so yeah that's how that works but but
i'm the crook
and i'm the one that doesn't know what
he's talking about according to that
industry
now if you want some people pissed off
at you that's a good group of people to
have pissed off at you
the time share people are pissed off at
me yeah the
car fleecing people are pissed off at me
the payday lenders hate my guts
and the whole life people oh my god you
would
think i would have you taken on the rent
to own furniture people yet
you know they just don't do much anymore
right okay i'm just trying to think of
anybody else while we're
we should just go ahead and get a full
list of the scum
people you don't get christmas cards
from yeah
yeah well i mean rent to own is
actually you know i have they are taking
on in a couple of our books and a couple
of our courses over here
yeah but i don't really hear from them
much yeah it's not a popular model yeah
the nothing down same as cash furniture
people they're not happy with me
no best buy screwing people with that
stuff for decades
yeah it's ain't the best buy people yeah
you know it's not hard to figure out
yeah
the product protection plan people they
don't like either yeah yeah
all the extras why is it that everybody
makes you the bad guy because you're
trying to save people money
well i'm just trying to save people
that's the point yeah
you're hurting the big corporate scams
and so that's why they come at you
yeah like everybody didn't already know
payday lenders were a screw job
like like all of america knows time
everybody knows a time share
is like the worst thing on the planet
yeah
and like they're shocked that dave
ramsey said it out loud the time shares
are scummy
yeah oh my god of course we said it out
loud they were scummy long before i
back when i had a hair they were scary
yeah well when you offer all these free
things just for a meeting which by the
way
i did it one time you didn't i did you
went in the tiger cage
yeah because the package was so nice and
they see the tiger for an
hour and you get a free pass to the zoo
for a year so stacey tiger hasn't eaten
in four days
but come in the cage and pet the tiger
for an hour oh here's the deal
i didn't pay attention to my wife this
is a great story yeah she's like you're
gonna have to sit there and listen i'm
like trust me i won't
i'm the guy that goes through this
there's no chance well i went in just mr
stonewall
not gonna do it like you're the only
one's ever done that i know and then sat
there and just got worn
out i tried to be rude i tried to get
kicked out
i'll give the guy credit he made me sit
there for 90 minutes but i'll tell you
what i got all the stuff too
so that was it it was the last time i
was in it it was not worth it it's our
first year of marriage buy your own
hotel room yes buy your own hotel room
it ain't worth it no don't pet the tiger
in the tiger cage
yeah it's good he will eat your butt
yeah you'll come out of there with a 26
thousand dollar time share that's worth
a dollar
yeah you can't sell it for a dollar on
ebay you can't get out of it
no you is stuck baby you've been petting
a tiger don't go in the tiger cage
no wonder he hadn't eaten in three days
there's nothing as greedy as a timeshare
salesman
oh my god this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're a business owner or leader
listen up financial wellness
benefits are no longer quote unquote
optional
for your employee benefits package yeah
financial wellness is a thing
the research team here at ramsey
solutions recently put out a report that
found that
half of all employers say their
employees are stressed about money
yet only 18 percent feel responsible
for their employees financial well-being
well that doesn't make sense
your employees bring their money stress
through the front door
with them because they come to work with
it every
day it's hurting your business with
turnover missed work lost productivity
delayed retirements you got to fix this
team to get our team's report
on what's happening in the workplace
with financial wellness and learn what
the employees are actually facing
you can add financial wellness to your
benefits package and will help your
business
text wellness to 33789
wellness to 33789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from jennifer in texas she writes in i'm
48 and i've been in an industry for 20
years that i'm not passionate about i've
done
well but i'm burned out and feel trapped
i would love to go into nursing
am i crazy to quit my job to go into a
career where i'll make less than
one-third of the income
if i stick it out for two to three years
we could pay off our house and i could
just quit completely but i'm not ready
to retire
is the financial and emotional roi from
nursing school worth going back to
school
or should i stick it out well let's
first address the fact that you can work
full-time while in nursing school
is it very very difficult yes but you
can do it
you can certainly work part-time in
healthcare even
where you can get some experience and
more importantly connections for nursing
when you get out of school
so i when you know the reality that you
can still work
that you can cash flow your way through
nursing school here's what you can
realize you might be able to pay off
the house in two to three years while
you're cash flowing your way through
nursing school
and if it's really about love i would
love to go into nursing so if you really
love the idea of caring for people
in that nursing profession you can make
really good money be very very fulfilled
for another 10 you know years 10 12
years based on
your age so is it worth it you have to
answer that
but i would say it's worth it if you can
cash flow your way through
and not go into debt because you've
worked so hard
to get to a point where you're going to
pay off the house so sticking it out for
two or three years in a job you can't
stand
i don't think you need to do that i
would make preparations to
part-time nursery school or if you can
go full time and make some other
sacrifices
i think you go for it i completely agree
completely agree and if the you know her
last question is the financial and
emotional roi
from nursing home school worth going
back to school yes without question
you'll love your work and you'll make
good money yes and you can pay off the
house
yeah yeah and uh i don't think you have
to stay in the job i agree for two to
three years
and i love the part-time idea so
absolutely
so yeah the thing is this
you know but make sure that you love
nursing not you love the idea of it
and i and not you love um
the money you could make that's correct
so here's how you know that
for those of you who are looking at this
question in a different field or maybe
even nursing how do you do that
so what she does is she gets around
other nurses
this is phone calls zooms coffees
lunches and by the way there's tons of
different types of nursing
uh er labor delivery checking people in
at surgery
there's a lot of different nursing
positions and by talking to
you know as many nurses as you can in
all those different positions here's
what happens
i get head knowledge they tell me what
it's like day in day out
what it's like to move into that
position how you advance you learn
everything and then what happens is your
brain processes that information dave
your heart eventually goes ding ding
ding or
and that's why it's so important to
really know what it is
then your heart will confirm and now
you're ready to go don't just assume
you're going to love it
joe's in louisville kentucky hi joe
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well my fiance and i she's not
a u.s citizen but she's lived here for
about eight years we plan to go back to
europe or move back to europe for
a year to two years while we do the
application process for
her permanent residency and i'm curious
if you think i should sell
my house or not
uh yeah yeah i would it's a great time
to sell a house
okay and then if i do sell my house what
should i do with that extra money i
think i would have
somewhere between eighty and a hundred
thousand dollars
you don't have any debt we would we have
no debt
uh which are our finances are completely
separated now
sure um but we're um but we have no debt
neither one of us other than
the mortgage and um her family has a
place for us to stay
for the time we're there so we would be
living rent free we both work remotely
okay so your incomes won't change
correct
that's cool what do you all make
i make about a hundred thousand i'm
self-employed to engineering
and she is in marketing and makes around
50.
excellent cool when are you getting
married
um well that's that's a a big question
we haven't planned all that it'll
probably be
sometime in 2022 okay
all right um
yeah i i i i think i would as far as
where you park it
if you're going to park it for one year
probably just a money market account
you're not going to make any money but
you're not going to lose any money if
you're going to park it for two years or
more
you may want to consider putting part of
that into some
mutual funds something like a uh an
index fund an s p 500 fund or something
like that i do some of that
but now i understand that that money
goes up and down and you could lose
a few thousand or you could make a few
thousand doing that
um sure you know you're not gonna lose
80 000 doing that but you might lose
uh eight you know uh or something like
that so that you
gotta if you want to play that a little
bit you could that's a
medium risk way to take a chance of
you know instead of making eight dollars
you might make eight thousand dollars
but
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
rich on any of this well it's just
sitting there
as you're just parking it until you're
married and come back home
and so forth so uh obviously this
citizenship
thing changes when you're married right
yes and the process is delayed due to
covid there's a big waiting list so
that's
she hasn't seen her family in quite a
while so that's why we're choosing to do
that in europe we could do that here but
we kind of have to stay put
can't be in and out of the border while
that process has taken place
oh really that's interesting as far as
we know
yeah okay i don't i don't know how it
works honestly i'm
completely ignorant of that i just know
that when you're you marry an american
citizen it
changes the process uh substantially
uh and so you know i i would guess
that the sooner the marriage happened
the sooner the citizenship would happen
in other words but
i think i would want to know about that
uh
i heard that advice and i'm just sitting
there going what would i do in that
situation
and because of the medium risk factor
i'd probably park it in the money market
but i
because that me going i i know that it's
going to sit there it's not going to
gain much at all but i know it's there
we're going to keep making money keep
adding to that so then when we come back
yeah but i mean but there is a benefit i
mean the money you could make i guess
to me it felt like too risky for me yeah
for the
bulk of the time i've been on the air i
would have just said money market right
for that reason just don't worry about
it yeah and because uh
but you know in the last decade or so
i've parked a lot of money
short-term mm-hmm yeah
you know and a time or two it's been
down
i pulled out because i was going to go
buy some real estate with it it was down
and i had lost a little bit
my timer most the time though it was up
and i made a lot
yeah uh during the time it sat there uh
and so
what i started realizing was the risk
wasn't that heavy it's not that big it's
not huge
i mean eight thousand dollars isn't
gonna change his life that's to make 150
000 between them
yeah you know so if you want to play
with it that's fine but if it's
emotionally going to keep you up at
night then certainly do
the money market yeah this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jc is with us hey jc how are you i'm
great how are you dave
better than i deserve welcome good to
have you
and where do you live indianapolis
indiana wow
welcome to nashville and all the way
down here to do a debt-free scream
that is right love it how much have you
paid off
i have paid off nineteen thousand
dollars oh wait 19
188 dollars good how long did this take
um it took 14 months wow and your range
of income during that time
i started out at about 24
and bumped it up to a little over 36
000. good for you what do you do for a
living
monday through thursday i am a dental
assistant
and then i have been a dog groomer for
the last seven
years so i do that on the weekends
that's your side hustle then
okay very cool what kind of debt was the
19 000
it was a endless cycle of credit cards
and then my student loan and my car
how much did you owe on the student loan
in the car
3 500 on the student loan and my car was
9
000. okay all right and that i paid to
my parents
ah that was a debt to my parents so it's
good to get rid of that too
yeah that was a big deal yeah i hear you
i hear you so what happened 14 months
ago
lit you on fire girl you got after it
yeah um well i
was working for a um grooming salon
and they had unexpectedly just
closed the shop like so they told us
they were done and they were filing
bankruptcy
and we were out of a job whoa so i
was like man i have a lot of debt like
start of the year
i had a lot of debt i had lost my job
and so
i uh just decided to that it was time to
figure something else out
i didn't really want to work for anyone
else in that like grooming so
i started up my own thing that was but
you were already working the dental
yeah at that time okay so you had that
job all along but that that side job
ended yeah and that woke you up yeah
cause i i
really wasn't making too much money at
the dentist job like
i can make a bunch of money just
grooming so that was where i really
made a lot of my money okay all right
wow good for you
well congratulations and how did you get
connected to us
my parents have listened to you guys for
a while and i they mentioned some things
um about you and uh they've always said
you know
i'm really not been one to be super
responsible with money
more of a free spirit um so
i wanted to kind of prove to them that i
could really stick to something
and and you know get it done and
especially when it came to my finances
so
they knew that i had been in credit card
debt for a long time and
i just it would come the start of the
year my tax return would come and it'd
all go to
my credit card debt so i was done doing
that
so what did you do you started listening
to youtube or watching youtube podcasts
on spotify
broadcast every day to and from work
every day
okay got real serious about it and that
gave you everything you needed to do
this
it sure did yeah so you didn't have the
books or anything from your paper
no but i did end up going to the
bookstore and
i found one of your older books the
total money makeover
and i started reading that um and then i
decided to sign up for the fpu class
oh okay and i was like man 100
should i spend that like it could go to
my debt i'm like
ramsay said just do it so i did the
fpu class and it was definitely worth it
it was a little difficult because it was
online during covid yeah
so i did the best i could with my
three-year-old running around
so but but it was still fine and worth
it i mean i stuck to it
good for you i'm proud of you i bet your
mom and dad are
they sure are they really are they were
cheering you along yeah
it was it was a big deal for christmas
instead of getting a bunch of presents
i saved up two thousand dollars and gave
it to them to put towards my car
wow and uh that meant a lot to them
they really were not expecting it at all
and so
to see them you know hear them talking
about how proud of me they were
and you know just the hug from my dad
and the pat on my back and you know it
just it got me fired up to finish paying
off the rest so
that's cool yeah wow very cool you
jumped from 24 000
to 36 and i'm guessing here is that some
overtime but also a lot of dog grooming
all dog a lot of weekends yes without
the little man i mean
i miss him a lot the hardest part was
being away from him that much
i mean it was monday through thursday
full time at the dentist job
and then thursday night into sunday i
was grooming like
every single weekend what kept you going
he did that's beautiful right there my
three-year-old that's beautiful
yep and i have the greatest
accountability
partner which is the doctor i work for
tony
um every day and he knew how much this
meant to me
um every day he'd come in and we would
be talking about the weekend how many
dogs you have to groom this weekend
how busy you going to be how much money
you're going to make and it just was
like
you got to stick to it you know a lot of
my time went to that
and now i can say it's worth it now
you're free yeah
how's it feel i can breathe
that's that's how it feels i can breathe
finally how old are you
26. 26 years old and you've never been
debt-free as an adult have you
no no it was almost like having a credit
card was
a competition how much did you get
approved for you know my credit limit's
4 000. what's yours
that was like my 21 year old mindset
yeah
yeah so got you in trouble wow
yeah you have to feel
uh one lady said accomplished
i mean this was a not just a 19 000 debt
paid off you changed
i did i've changed so much through this
whole
experience i mean i really thank you so
much for this i i don't know how
to say it but it's just it's been so
eye-opening like i can
raise him without having to worry you
know
all my monies go into my debt and not to
what i could be doing
more for him you know i've got his
savings fund for his college started
i've got my retirement fund going
thanks to thanks to tony you know he
he's really helped me out too he's it's
awesome coached you alone
oh yeah that is just so cool well well
done
well done jc and your young man's name
and age you want to get him in the shot
for the debt free scream
his name is cyprus and he is three you
want to come up here
come up with mom while we do your
debt-free scream she's worked her tail
end off she's a hero
she's changed her whole life man i'm so
proud of you
so powerful so well done good stuff
all right it's jc and cyprus from
indianapolis
man nineteen thousand dollars paid off
in
14 months making 24 to 36.
uh we are looking at some people who
have changed their lives i'm so proud of
you
got a copy of the uh legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter for you to
become
wealthy now unbelievably and you are on
your way i'm so proud of you and a copy
of the total money makeover
so you can give it away to somebody
awesome so we'll give you one of each
you ready all right jc and cypress count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one i'm debt free
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man
that nineteen thousand dollars when
you're making 24
to 36. it's getting with it that's
that's more than some doc calling in
here paying off 190 grand
yeah i mean that's incredible yeah what
she pulled off there
was absolutely incredible yeah and she
is
i mean the and the difference in weight
on her
after that the actual math the the
freedom in her math now
is just it's just amazing she is in
really really good shape and you can see
what you guys can't see in the radio you
can hear hints of it in her voice but
what you can see is on her face
yeah her countenance yeah
you can see the sense of uh uh she's a
young warrior
yeah another single mom behind the eight
ball
and yet she said enough and she did it
that's getting with it folks 19 000 14
months with a heavy heart
upped her eyeballs and dog fur she did
it
she did it well that's exactly how that
is
yeah there's a great place to go when
you're broke no work that's right
i love it this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today ii corinthians 9 8
and god is able to bless you abundantly
so then all things at all times
having all that you need you will abound
in every good work
winston churchill said the pessimist
sees difficulty in every opportunity the
optimist sees opportunity
in every difficulty
my fico score is zero
i don't have a fico score it's
undeterminable
that's what they call it sounds kind of
evil
but yeah i'm undeterminable so how do i
survive how do i make it
i pay for things and if i don't
pay for them i don't buy them now i know
that's weird
but it's a it's a it's a freeing concept
keeps you out of debt you can teach your
children to be counter cultural
in a culture that has lost its mind
and we've just dropped prices up to 80
on our best-selling kids products so you
can have fun
and have an educational summer the
adventure pack is a family favorite that
includes the new story time collection
financial piece junior the smart saver
bank
and more to make learning about money
actually fun the best part is you can
add an extra kit for each sibling
or if you've got a teen the teen
entrepreneur toolbox
by anthony o'neill is the perfect safe
and flexible way for them to create
their own summer job
teach kids the right way to handle money
while they're young that way they won't
live in their bait your basement when
they're 30.
save up to 80 percent off by shopping
the kids and teens
sale online at ramseysolutions.com store
ramsey solutions dot com slash store
tina is with us in phoenix hi tina
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken how are you guys doing
great how can we help
yes so i talked to ken last week and i
wanted to thank you ken for your advice
well that's awesome what would you do so
i i was not getting a recommendation
from my boss
and your advice was to flood
the potential employers in box with
references that could speak of my
character
and so with it being a long weekend i
did that today
and after a couple of years came through
they said they would like to speak with
me
and it as long as everything goes
through tomorrow i'm going to meet with
the
teachers and that goes smoothly then i
will have a job and they said they were
very understanding of
that sometimes relationships just don't
match and but they're willing to give me
a chance
oh i remember this so tina i want to
tell dave what happened so
tina had great references from previous
teaching positions but had a personality
conflict
with the principal at the school that
she just left she was worried that
because they wanted to hire this new
school wanted to hire but that one
uh leader wouldn't give her a
recommendation and so i told her well do
you have a lot of other relationships in
the school system
that can vouch for how great you are and
that this was kind of
an outline circumstances so she went and
did it and uh
looks like she's gonna get that
opportunity so good for you teen a way
to not quit
you did that you're the one that went
out there and believed that you had a
reputation
uh worth uh sharing and uh that's really
awesome
very cool tina yeah i thank you guys for
the advice i really appreciate it so i
just wanted to say thanks
it worked yeah thank you you did it you
went out and fought for it
fight for things folks yeah but you know
what you told her she could and exactly
what to do and she just executed she
went and did it yeah
and you know sometimes we tell people
what to do and they go home and
don't do it you know that's right like
too often um
and then they call us two years later i
should have done it but then
then other times that's that's why we
come down here
it's people like her that's exactly
right you say go do this and you'll
start winning and she goes does that and
then she starts winning
that's pretty cool it's fun got the job
got the job the ken coleman
job technique there it is i love it
that is absolutely fabulous amy is in
sacramento hi amy
welcome to the ramsey show hi thank you
so much for having me on
sure what's up um all right so i
started a business last year while i was
laid off
um and then i got called back to work
right as i was about to start looking
for clients
i'm really eager to quit at least by
april
of 2022 and focus on my business
full-time
it's a bookkeeping business if i didn't
mention that and
um we already have six months worth of
an emergency fund
saved up we plan on having an additional
twelve thousand dollars
by next april the thing is my husband
has a job
where he gets laid off quite often he's
in a labor union
um so we would only be able to last
about
five and a half months on that extra 12k
if my husband were to get laid off
otherwise
how long how often is he laid off for
five and a half months
i mean he was like in the last two years
he was laid off once for
six months um other than that i would
say
usually like maybe three four months on
average
man this job sucks yeah i'd be getting
out of the union
it does suck but we're waiting until he
gets his journeyman card because then
you can quit and you can take that
anywhere you can work for the city
or something like that yeah we're in it
for the long game unfortunately
yeah okay so how long before he gets the
tournament card
um so i think it'll be probably another
like three or four years
wow you're tolerating a lot of crap for
that
you know so every time he gets laid off
he doesn't get hours
um but anyways so if he gets laid off we
could last on
on that extra 12 000 for about five and
a half months
um otherwise we'd have to dig into the
six-month emergency fund or i'd have to
get a job again um
what do you think about that am i crazy
for wanting to quit when i'm gonna
what is i mean you're assuming your
business makes nothing
i mean i don't i just don't want to
estimate that i mean is your business
not made any money
all right i mean right now i have two
monthly clients i'm netting
aside from like cleanup work that's
one-time projects
um i'm only netting like 300 a month
obviously
you don't have a business yet you got a
glorified hobby
right well the reason why i want to quit
and go full time
is because i'm still like learning the
business
and i want to focus my attention a
hundred percent no
wrong way you got to flip that you got
to keep doing these side
side jobs like this let's get that up to
900 a month and then let's get it to
1500 a month and let's see how many
hours
we can actually give to it and really
really hustle
and grow your credibility based on your
experience but you don't go
all in until you get experience 100 a
month yeah you get experience
then you build it up okay
so what if i were to take a part-time
with a full-time job no your part-time
job is learning this side hustle
and growing this side hustle that's
correct no this
listen you cannot justify giving up your
whole career
and giving up everything and walking
into something that's 300 freaking
dollars a month you have got to
prove this i mean not right now i know
it's right now so prove me wrong
go make some dadgum money you do
whatever you want to do kiddo but i'm
telling you that's dumb
don't do that yeah okay yeah let's
incrementally
let's get let's go from two clients to
three or four clients or let's let's
drop the two clients replace them with
with more work from clients that'll give
you more work we want to get your
billable as
a bookkeeper this is all about your
billable time
what you have is a theory right now yeah
you need to move it from
theory to business yeah a business is
something that makes money
ongoing that is substantial that you can
live on
you need to grow a business and as the
business gets up close to what you're
making now then you quit your full time
but you will have proven your ability to
make
money doing this you have to do that
and you've got this dream in your head
that if you just go full time it's all
going to work out honey it's not how it
works
because you haven't figured out how to
run this dadgum business yet you haven't
figured out how to make money with it
and you got to go make some
money that's the whole goal here
everybody's willing to do what it takes
very few are willing to wait as long as
it takes and that's where you
are the tension for you right now is you
don't want to wait because you really
love this bookkeeping and you get this
day job you want to get rid of here's
the problem
you're not ready your day job's going to
fund the dream job go
build the side business yep build it get
the dock get the boat closer to the dock
don't be jumping in the water thinking
you're
hitting the boat the boat's way out
there still yeah you need to get it up
closer so you can land in the boat when
you jump
please please do that
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
you